welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on why sometimes
the villain might just be right i mean
sure some cities may need to be
destroyed and some of your morals may
need to be compromised but in the end
you'll see why all those people had to
die
my name is mt and with me
don't turn to the dark side
everyone at new rocks i couldn't do that
too much my name is mt and i'm here
today with off-screen producer brandon
what's going on brandon oh not much mt
you know just here to give more reasons
why we should be liking the villains
what's wrong with us why are we always
on the villain side sometimes you got to
play mad titan's advocates of you know
it's
occasionally yeah it's true i don't know
if it wasn't
is it the deleted version of i am legend
or the real version of i am legend i
don't remember but at the end when the
monsters are like you're our monster to
will smith then it's like oh
oh dang he was killing us all right hit
me with that big question brandon okay
mt so now that we've had some time post
mcu's infinity war and end game and a
few more movies and series have come out
and been released uh we're starting to
see the actions of our favorite mad
titan thanos in a whole new light okay
in fact it's made us even start to
question our own feelings on the events
that took place in end game okay that
leads us to this week's big question
was thanos right
right
right was the house right well
answer no of course not murder is never
okay
listen if you're thinking about
murdering half of humanity don't do it
don't take a walk instead go to your
local um grocery store have a banana
that's what i'm saying
eat a banana feel better by yourself put
some food on your stomach get some
potassium in the snickers maybe instead
of committing genocide yeah a lot of
positive banana clarity that's what
everyone's looking for out there maybe
though it is well it's sort of
complicated it's of course it's not okay
but like it's okay let's get into it
because this is something we've
discussed before on the channel because
we've looked into the long lasting
effects both good and bad that the snap
would have on society culture
governments industry and the environment
but now that we're a few years past
endgame we've learned a lot more about
how the cosmic side of things work in
the mcu and it's put thanos's plan into
a whole new light so let's go through
some of those revelations and see if
what we now know makes us view thanos in
a better or less murdery light or less
bad light you know in a whole new light
i guess
yeah it's still pretty murdery but maybe
they're still very murdery you know what
i'm not yeah i'm not trying to excuse
thanos they just did a terrible thing
and i'm glad that mother is dead but
if thanos was real i'd be my anxiety to
be a lot worse than it is and it's
pretty bad let me tell you
but anyway i'm glad
too i love that when thor is like mad
jabbed his head off
and i'll do it again
but hey i feel like fat thor was well
deserved because after if you killed the
titan i'm gonna have doritos and
brownies for a very long time in
celebration i'm just gonna tell you that
right i agree and we've seen the set
photos we know he's back in shape again
he's the women and most of the men of
america are happy that he's in good
shape again but
you know we're not mean
respect fat thor please respect i'm not
i'm not a fan of in shape four because
that means excuse me that there's less
women for me
[Laughter]
thor is taking all our women and some of
our men
when people ask me empty why are you
single i'm like it's because chris
hemsworth man i don't know what to say
they gotta fix this the chris hemsworth
probably this is where you need the
jesse pinkman meme right he can't keep
getting away you can't keep getting away
with this he can't keep getting away
with it anyway let's begin with the big
cosmic baby that was hiding inside of
earth just waiting to bust out and kill
us all tiamet our favorite celestial
inside of earth because in the eternals
we learn about the emergence the event
that would see the birth of a brand new
bouncing baby celestial named tiamet and
arashim tells cersei the truth about
where the baby celestials come from and
it's not as fun as uh
as you think because it turns out you
think it would be it's not as sexy uh
you don't need a blue chew for this one
it turns out you just need to kill a
whole planet full of intelligent life
energy just to turn one celestial seed
into a fully grown celestial and i don't
know why celestial came out of earth
because i don't think there's a lot of
intelligent life here these days
sorry not to get topical but yes you
have to destroy the whole planet to set
the celestial free but that's just life
in the cosmos baby i mean
sorry the celestials don't make the
rules
well actually you know the celestials do
make the rules so i don't know why they
just don't figure out a different way to
grow babies but yeah i mean
that's a pretty strong point empty why
are they doing it this way you couldn't
think of anything else you build armies
of robot eternals and defense right
figure out a new way to make a baby come
on that hurts less people i don't know i
feel like there's lack of imagination
irish in i don't know are you trying to
say i have no imagination yes but we
also learned from ajax and eternals that
when thanos snapped away half the people
on earth he also delayed the emergence
so i guess thank you is in order to
thanos thank you for uh delaying our
inevitable advice
but now whether or not the delaying of
the emergence was something thanos was
trying to do we can't say for sure i
mean he did seem more concerned about
working through his own trauma from the
effects of overpopulation and resource
scarcity on titan than you know stopping
the birth of a celestial because you
know he just seemed like he was just
really upset that no one listened to him
and he was like i was right i was right
and no one listened to me so i'm just
gonna exert my will in the universe i'm
right you're wrong shut up
but that's because his monologuing to
tony and the gang only gave us that
insight but giving his knowledge around
infinity stones one would think that he
would also know about celestials by
stepping away half of life in the
universe was he also trying to stop the
birth of any more celestials that's a
great point empty because yeah
thanos must know about celestials right
he's got
his papa wasn't eternal his brother's is
an eternal i mean uh it's a it's harry
styles
we already knew he was eternal so
clearly he knows about celestials and he
must know about how celestials get born
by now unless his dad never got out of
the programming matrix i don't know how
they're going to handle it in the mcu
but it seems like eros knows what's
going on right he's like let's go to
aeroshem let's get him back and let's
stop all these emergencies emergencies
oh that's cute
yeah was he really doing did he really
just care about like balancing the
universe or was there a part of him
that's like also i hate these celestials
and is that maybe what happened to titan
was it just resource scarcity or did
maybe you know a celestial pop out of
there it didn't fully destroy the planet
but is that what messed up the gravity
and caused all the breakage i don't know
um
it's i think it's quite possible that
there was a some type of emergence or
like maybe the like because the the
people of the planet died early uh there
was a pre-termination of the baby ahead
of time so like you know yeah i think
that you know he's definitely got to be
aware of the celestial thanos like
that's definitely got to be on his mind
to some degree and because the
celestials do
end up destroying life and like and
thanos's whole thing is the managing of
life and like the keeping it from
getting too overgrown or too less like
that's why he's a farmer at the end of
infinity war that's why he goes to a
farm because he's basically being a
farmer yeah i think that it just makes
sense that he would be against the
celestial agenda of just you know using
planets as eggs and so he would just be
like all right you guys don't know that
your eggs i don't want to really uh jar
you because like if you just told
everybody yeah your planet's an egg that
would really up a lot of planets
you know yeah he could go around telling
people like oh there's a celestial in
here and it's gonna burst out and so we
need to wipe out half of you sorry but
i'm right but i think that's a lot to
download on people right he's not gonna
tell tony like i need to explain to you
how the cosmos was created and where the
infinity stones came from and how
celestials are made and how they are
created and
also this is why i'm doing it like he
doesn't have time for all that but tony
understands like population control he
understands the need for resources so
he's like i'm just gonna tell dumb
idiots in the universe this story
everyone else i can explain it to
like this is what's going to happen well
like you know he people didn't listen to
him the first time so i feel like he's
not really inclined to explain himself
he's like people are stupid they
unders thing it's like i am the only
that was don't
person with the will to do that what is
necessary and we sort of see that with
mordo too it's like this thing with like
when i love when doctor strange one of
the mortals says in response to doctor
strange doesn't have imaginations like
you lack a spine no steven you
lack
a spine and like that's the whole thing
with with villains it's like you need a
spine to do what's gonna make a tough
cause you gotta make the tough calls but
yeah i think that um the celestials are
uh on thanos's list for for sure
so i i mean i love this idea that he's
like i'm going to wipe this i don't love
the idea
[Music]
caveat
i think it's for motivation for thanos
to be yes i'm worried about scarcity in
the universe and balance and blah blah
blah but also i've got to stop these
celestials they ruin my family they ruin
my planet i gotta go you know i think it
was arashem said in eternals either
every million years or billion years
like a celestial is created every
billion years
new celestials must be born but i also
don't know if it's only one at a time
like if tiamat had been born would it
not be another million years till an
emergence happens it seems like too long
i don't know the in the grand scheme of
the cosmos who knows we don't know how
many celestials are out there roaming
around you know they get invented all
the time in the comics they'll pop up a
new one here and there so i don't know
and it would be interesting if like part
of the fall of titan was also a
celestial getting out there maybe they
tried to cut it out an emergency section
if you will
get that that celestial seat out of the
planet and that's what destroyed it and
thanos was like no screw this i'm just
gonna wipe out the baby food and that's
the living beings in the universe
but another thing to consider here is
what dr strange learned when he was
viewing the 14 million 605 outcomes for
the avengers battle with thanos in one
of those realities did he see a scenario
where the avengers were able to stop
thanos before the snap but then the
earth gets wrecked when tiamat pops out
not long after so is that why he was
willing to let tony and natasha
sacrifice themselves because you know he
sort of saw what was to come that would
be crazy right he's like watching all of
them and he sees the one like oh they
beat they don't you know like they stop
peter before peter quill before he like
punches thanos in the face or something
they stop him they kill thanos and they
all go back home and they're like this
is great we're having a great time and
then just boom they're all dead he's
like
fast forward fast forward
different outcome all the sorcerers we
know that like the mystic arts people
know about the celestials right because
juan and wong explained the whole thing
so they must know so it's crazy to think
that like yeah doctor strange maybe saw
team or like destroy the earth and he's
like oh this is bad so so we have to let
thanos at least do the snap to delay the
events because even if thanos hadn't if
thanos hadn't snapped and the emergence
happens earlier like ajax was saying the
eternals wouldn't have been in the right
mindset to even stop it right they
wouldn't even know they'd be spread to
the wind they'd have no clue that it was
coming so that would it would have just
happened and nothing would have stopped
it so thanos kind of had to do the snap
to stop the emergence right oh yeah for
sure and so i feel like the snap
happening and you know the eternals
watching humanity go through the snap
and rally together from the snap i feel
like really may have pushed them to want
to protect humanity even more yeah the
snap really did have to happen for the
events of eternals to take place in the
way that they did i think it's really
possible that dr strange did see this as
one of the events
and even though he knows in the in the
one way it plays out one way that tony
and natasha both like die among other
people die right but like that we know
of our heroes tony and tasha have to
sacrifice themselves in order to get
that far
to undo it he's willing to let that
happen i mean we saw you know dr strange
had no way home was ready to let anyone
die to keep the universe rolling along
doesn't matter yeah he told a teenager i
will let you die i don't care about you
i don't feel tripped it's just like they
gotta go back they gotta die sorry
that's how they're gonna be here so it
doesn't surprise me that dr strange is
like well i can let tony and natasha die
if it prevents the earth from exploding
so that's how it's got to be and this
this further feeds into my theory that
we have the evil doctor strange on our
plane
i mean it's quite possible because he
just he literally just does whatever he
wants i'll just do it you're the most
evil one out there i don't know i don't
know
but another thing we've learned about
recently is the dweller in darkness
and one thing the dweller in darkness
loves to eat is souls yum yum yum yummy
souls he loves soul food and i can
relate it's delicious and the souls are
the source of the dweller's powers we
still don't know about where the dweller
comes from or who the ten rings started
to send a beacon out to when the dweller
was killed but did thanos know about
this threat and wanted to reduce the
number of souls available for feasting
that's that's an interesting uh thought
there mt because i i imagine that
dweller lives in another dimension i
think you've talked about this before
you think he's like an interdimensional
being right yeah and that's part of all
this dark magic stuff we're getting into
in this phase of the mcu so it would be
interesting that if he was like i know
there's this beast out there and it'll
just consume souls and get stronger as
it consumes them and it could be a
threat to me
ruling the universe even though thanos
doesn't want to rule the universe he's
supposed to be a farmer he could be a
threat to my farm i don't know
eating all my craps so i gotta get rid
of these souls before he can eat it
thanos watches a bug life and he's like
what the yeah
do something not in my farm no one's
doing minecraft i mean i'll put my armor
up as a scarecrow but we gotta that's
not gonna stop the dweller
that'd be
my dummy he blasts my tummy
well yeah because like you know zwell
and darkness as we see from shanghai
just by getting a few souls from the
people from tallow was able to power up
like fairly
a lot like it was fairly substantially
and so um if he had an entire planet of
souls
maybe he could have just ascended to god
like levels so like we don't really know
what was going to happen if he was to uh
suck the soul of the great protector so
maybe thanos knows that there there is a
whole race of these guys and they're
like they're coming and like we need to
make sure that like these souls they
don't have enough food to become these
huge like maybe dormammu levels of of
godhood yeah whoever's in charge of the
dweller or you know is connected to the
dweller and is using the dweller
obviously has other creatures that
probably eat souls as well you know the
little soul suckers they they took the
souls to papa you know he maybe just in
general he's like whatever this dark
creature is or whoever rules this dark
dimension probably mamu but whoever i
got to keep him from getting more souls
and getting more powerful gotta stop the
celestials gotta stop the darkness i
gotta stop the band the darkness and
then go start my farm yeah just
basically just controlling the food
source is you know what farmers sort of
do it's what farmers do let's also
consider the kang of it all because is
there any way that thanos wielding the
infinity stones to cut the population of
the universe in half was an attempt to
dilute the powers of king the conqueror
hmm do you think thanos knows about kang
i guess that's the first part right you
think he's aware of kang the conqueror
do you think he's encountered a version
of kang somewhere i think that it is
possible that thanos has encountered a
version of kang that he didn't know that
he encountered but i think that any
knowledge of kang might have come after
he snapped the after he got all of the
infinity stones because as we saw in
what if when ultron fan when ultron
vision got all the infinity stones
that's when he was able to you know have
awareness beyond this
existence yeah yeah and so
i could see thanos just snapping and
just being like after he sees little
baby gamora in his mind just being like
wait a minute that's that's a black man
up there
and he's dead he's in charge of
everything
it's famous actor jonathan
[Applause]
up there in the sky i can't love anymore
anyway i wish i hadn't snapped away
hollywood because i loved his work great
stuff yeah i don't know if thanos knows
about kang because i feel like our mcu
was very tightly controlled by the tva
uh and it was keeping out all the other
kangs right maybe someone in his little
entourage knew about kang like the magic
guy ebony ma ebony maw maybe he knew
about kang and he was taunting us like
also there's this council of men out
there that want to take each other and
fight each other and thanos is like i
don't need all that i'm just trying to
have one i don't need all please okay i
don't care i don't care ebony like what
if kang was an eternal oh like a king
variant at least
oh and like the the celestials are using
their eternal kang to like have another
version of control like they got up they
got a bunch of plant they have so much
time they have all these like little
fail safes hidden around just to screw
us living beings so they can
feed us to their babies someone's got to
do something great
do something about it i think that druid
honestly drug is probably going to come
and kill all the celestials oh baby
when that guy mind controls a celestial
and just uses it to wreck house that's
going to be bro he's going to he's
probably going to mind control and tell
them all to dead themselves
which would be very dark but like i
could see him doing it
okay and finally in the marvel what if
series that came out last year we were
introduced to a dangerous zombie virus
that existed in one of the universes out
there in the multiverse and in that
universe zombie thanos was well on his
way to collecting the sixth and final
infinity stone so is there some way that
the main mcu's thanos could have known
about the zombies counterpart and then
collected the infinity stones as sort of
a protection against that zombie thing
i love that idea because it was
insinuated that the zombie virus came
from the quantum realm right very
dangerous probably created by celestials
because they're monsters so this idea
that it exists and maybe this is another
thing where like ebony ma was like also
sir
there's a
virus out there
there's a version of you that's a zombie
and he's got all these stones and he's
gonna come he's like fine whatever i'll
get the stones stop bugging me ebony ma
you're always so creepy right behind me
so it was like a warning he was like
well i gotta get these stones just in
case he comes to my dimension or my
universe and we can stomp this virus
because there's got to be a version of
me that's got his head on straight who's
focused who's farming and is like ready
to take control i mean the only thing
that really trips me up is the fact that
thanos destroyed the stones but i still
think maybe he didn't he used the stones
to destroy the stones
liar
maybe he just said he did maybe he made
a thing look like they were destroyed
but i don't think he did i think he knew
better because how could we have
imagined if thanos left a treasure hunt
he's like in case i died i left a
treasure hunt so you could find the
infinity stones out of the galaxy four
dead man's chest here we go
to the caribbean yo nicholas cage make
nicholas cage star-lord let's do
national treasure
yeah there's a version of there's a
multiverse version of star-lord that's
uh nicholas cage
it's not even starla it's just nicholas
cage he was it's just nicholas playing
nicolas cage
well yeah you were saying earlier empty
that you know you brought up like ultron
vision how once he had the stones he was
aware of like the different universe i
mean he's also ultron was very smart and
was able to like do all that computation
he kind of gave him a little more
clairvoyance into how everything worked
but i don't doubt that you know on that
farm before thanos destroyed the stones
hashtag didn't destroy the stone you
know he's sitting around he's doing some
farming and he's like oh there is a
multiverse out there you know he does
get a glimpse he sees jonathan majors
and he's like this is great
and then he sees the wine this is great
what's going on here he's like get out
of my business or watch you i'm a farmer
now i do like that idea that he gets the
stones and he sees like there's this
threat out there maybe he sees what it
all is and that's what drives them to
destroy them or at least act like they
were destroyed so no one else in this
universe tries to get them and then
create creates all this problem i think
i like that idea that thanos was like
i'm gonna wipe out half i don't like the
idea
i respect yeah
thanos was like i'm gonna wipe out half
the living life in this universe that
will that will stop the celestials from
getting so powerful that'll stop the
dweller in darkness that'll put a a
wrench in king's plans that'll prevent
this zombie virus from getting here and
i could just be a farmer okay that's all
i want to do i can just chill for him
then i could just chill
would someone be grateful for once ebony
don't stand behind me you're always
right behind me
hi
okay he's literally like uh that really
creep creepy kid that used to follow
helga pataki around and hey arnold just
like that
i don't want to say thanos was right
because he's not right he's not correct
was he driven yes
did he have oh yeah for sure some
altruistic goals in mind
yes but i don't think he's 100 right his
methods are sloppy and i don't like them
i think he could have taken a second
with the stones once he got them all to
maybe reflect before
just
you know full stop wiping everybody out
the second he could so i don't think he
was right in that aspect i think he was
right and that there's a lot of dangers
out there that we need to get ready for
that's all i'm saying and hey are you
one of those people who's always tired
and finding yourself reaching for an
extra coffee to get you through the day
you need a better way to energize and
nab jitsu offers time-released caffeine
to keep your energy steady throughout
the day that gypsu's natural supplements
were made by people who knows how it
feels to be tired and busy their
patent-pending formulas have natural
ingredients like b vitamins guarana and
ginseng to give you a boost of energy
without the crash later and each
napjitsu product provides brain boosting
nootropics to unlock steady energy right
when you need it and the result your
peak performance all day long and
napjitsu supplements are packaged into
small packets so you can take them
wherever and whenever you might need an
energy boost so whether you need to
experience deeper sleep or unlock
immediate lasting energy each napjitsu
product is designed to help you achieve
your optimal performance and remember
the smart rests more and the whys rest
better so rest up and level up with
napjitsu and for a limited time receive
30 off your first purchase when you go
to napjitsu.com big question go to
napjitsu.com
bigquestion for thirty percent off your
first purchase today that is n a p
j i t s u dot com slash big question
thank you to napture2 for sponsoring
this video well brandon now it is time
for our bite size question are you ready
buddy oh i'm ready for some bite size
questions
all right my friend if the armorer said
that mandalorian steel is meant for
armor not weapons then why did she make
the whistling birds fermando and this is
from flowest the super and the
nameless30 on twitter thank you guys so
much for this question so that's those
are this is a really good one yeah this
this was a good question we had a couple
people ask this question we listed two
of them there we asked a tweet recently
for some questions and this came in a
couple times and this regards a recent
plot point on an episode of the book of
boba fett really it was like the
mandalorian premiere of season three but
whatever what are you gonna do in that
episode we revisit our good friend mando
aka dinjarin who had made his way back
to the armorer and showing off the best
scar spear given to him by ahsoka last
season man the armorer is tough to say
armorer get a better name armor get over
yourself
seriously get a real name like jessica
yeah
so he's showing off this this cool spear
he got you know he made a new friend in
this jedi though he's not kind of cool
with jedi's iffy on them but the very
dogmatic armor gets on his case about it
and is like mandalorian steel shouldn't
be made into weapons because it can be
used against other mandalorians and you
know mandalorians really have trust
issues because it didn't go well for
them
um
so mandalorian steel is of course best
car and hold on a minute back in season
one of the mandalorian this very same
armorer
made the whistling birds out of best car
for our boy manto okay
who sh who's she trying to trick with
these little
slippers okay those little tiny wrist
missiles you know that we we saw shot
all over the place that's amazing okay
you're a hypocrite armorer you're insane
you're ugly you're disgusting i'm gonna
kill you give me 200
okay so there's a couple things to think
about here first okay we don't know
which part of the whistling birds are
best car okay is it the little munitions
themselves like the little bullets that
are best car or is it just like the
launch or his best car so that could be
like a loophole or it's like well the
bullets aren't
you know a launcher is not a weapon
without the things you launch i don't
know i don't know i i tend to think that
like the launcher is made of best car
because it wouldn't make sense to have
best guard bullets it's so valuable you
could like never shoot those off he's
gonna go dig him out of the people after
he shoots them off
i feel like your corpse is worth more
than you
would never shoot this thing off it's
like a million dollar rocket i don't
know what am i gonna do so her point
about the spear no pun intended uh makes
sense because you could anyone can like
use a spear and stab a mandalorian and
pierce the armor right but we don't even
know if like the whistling birds are
capable of piercing armor so she may not
see that as like a threat to other
mandalorians also i don't know if anyone
off the street can just pick up some
whistling birds and shoot him at you
know another mandalorian but anyone
could pick up the spear and stab him and
delorean so that's kind of i kind of see
that point where it's like the whistling
birds anyone can have these they're not
going to damage our cool ass armor okay
okay now here's my third point the armor
is like part of a pretty extreme cult of
mandalore that descended from the
children of the watch you know they're
the ones that sat on the moon and
watched the planet blow up and so while
and she practices these like super
ancient ways of mandalore it's not like
what she says is the truth for everybody
like that's part of their weird cult
remember they don't take their helmets
off and stuff other men delorean's like
bo katan they're like yeah we take our
helmet off we're cool it's fine i may be
screwed up as a leader but you know
things are going to be okay meanwhile
like the armor and you know her little
cult they're like we we wear a mess all
the time when they were down in the
tunnels their rules were like only one
person can go out at a time like i don't
everything she says shouldn't be taken
as like this is how it has to be this is
the rule of the universe okay so who
cares who cares if i made a weapon out
of this but you're not the
and some people also brought up the dark
saber since its hilt is made of best car
so it's like that's a weapon but the
saber blade itself can't even cut
through best car so it's not much of a
threat
i think her little cute saying was more
of like the you know the fortune cookie
version of we can't be making easy to
handle weapons out of best car that
anyone could use against a mandalorian
but that doesn't sound as good on the
show okay so they simplify
that's really i like that answer that i
really like what you said about the the
dark saber blade because that makes so
much sense yes like that like you're not
getting a weapon you can hit a
mandalorian with the hilt of it i guess
and her her tools are made of escar and
she was using them as weapons i mean
she's like sparring with him and stuff
so it's like you know it's more of like
a guideline than a rule okay okay
interesting all right brent i got
another question for you because in no
way home electro said he was absorbing
data right before he showed up so was
this the writer's attempt to explain how
he knew peter parker was spider-man and
is there any comic book reasoning that
could make that make sense and this is
from mixer hustle on twitter thank you
mixer hustle and keep hustling mikey
keep the hustle alive every day i'm
hustling
[Music]
so to your first point probably you know
probably that's probably what the
writers were doing they were saying he's
absorbing it that's how he knows because
the little rule of the spell was that
people who knew who peter parker was
were coming into our universe right or
who knew peter parker was spider-man and
in the movie directly they didn't point
out that max dillon ever knew that but
he was absorbing information right as he
died okay and he he specifically says in
the movie
quote i was whooping spider-man's ass
he'll tell you then he caused an
overload i was stuck in the grid
absorbing data and i was about to turn
into pure energy end quote so yes he was
absorbing all the information from the
grid which likely included computers
which were attached to the power grid
and those computers are attached to the
internet they have data there's probably
a computer at the os core in the amazing
spider-man universe that said peter
parker spider-man you know someone
probably wrote it down
so that's how he knew it and he was
getting all this data at once there are
some explanations of elektro's powers in
the comics that would explain this
ability in the comics he's able to
detect and manipulate electrical systems
right obviously and he's also able to
kind of sense them as well if he didn't
see them directly he knows they're there
and he's able to use this ability to
control electrical systems with his mind
you know he can disconnect alarm systems
and control computers so i i think that
makes sense right electro was originally
created in 1963 pre-modern internet but
it makes sense if he's able to control a
computer he would be able to retrieve
information from them especially if he's
in the process of like turning into pure
energy i think it makes sense that he
would be able to like get some of this
data okay so i think the comics do
support this this great
little you know writing trick they use
to get electro into no way home i think
it it clears the muster for me it clears
the must it does make sense cause like i
feel like another part of the amazing
spider-man 2 that people forget and like
you know with good reason because like
it's kind of had no payoff was that
peter was being spied on
like there was people outside like in a
van just being like oh that teenagers
are saying things what's she saying
um so they probably put two and two
together that this boy someone someone
typed it up on a computer an electro
exactly that's how it happens exactly
easy peas easy peasy but here's another
one for you buddy it's probably the
biggest question that people have in the
mcu my biggest question honestly this is
your friendly neighborhood flirting all
right brandon now it is time for our box
to scratch that box
[Music]
if you were to build your own theme park
what rides and ips would you include in
said theme park and this is from dj
serrano oh three on twitter thank you dj
thank you
so yeah so this is our own like
wizarding world of harry potter right
like what we want to build a super
immersive theme park with a specific ip
uh what what what would you build
i will say
you know i'm a big fan of disney
disneyland and you know they do a lot
and they already have you know they
created the pirates of the caribbean we
brought it up earlier but man if they
really went like all in with it and they
have like their park right you're you're
in the uh tortugas
in the tortugas
they feel like a tortugas it's like a
whole city and you can go on the ships
and there's a ride where like you get to
have your own ship and command it and
like fire at the other ships
you can dress like a pirate all day and
you can walk around and you can drink
rum and you can eat you can eat whatever
you want and it's like a whole beach
themed tropical like pirates experience
that'd be cool i mean i love the pirates
of the caribbean ride as it exists now
but maybe like a full immersive park you
know what i mean that would be really
awesome that would be so much fun i feel
like there would be so much shenanigans
in them so much people drunk oh yeah
it's not a safe place do not bring your
children to the private sector
but you know an adult only theme park
would be bananas yeah that would be
better oh my god i mean don't if you've
ever been to universal studios when they
do halloween horror nights that's uh
that's a pretty much adultery theme park
and it gets wild it gets crazy
oh my god i would love that so much
honestly you to start that so i could go
and feel like a pirate
i mean most renaissance fairs are
halfway there now it's like you go to
any renaissance fair it's mostly pirates
like i don't think this is the
renaissance but
but i think i would choose it's not it's
definitely the i was feeling this is the
opposite spectrum of yours oh good
animal crossing
honestly because animal everyone loves
animal crossing and i just think it's
they're just so cute and like isabelle
and like have like little tom nooks like
greet you and like have a little credit
system but like i just think that animal
crossing is so big and people love it so
much that like a whole animal crossing
world
bro that would make a bazillions of
dollars adorable um yeah either that or
uh just donkey kong
you want donkey kong country for real
that's what you want yes a whole donkey
kong country um but you know what just
make it diddy kongs because donkey kong
has enough diddy kong dixie and dd
cogs uh
theme park anyway
bananas only we only sell bananas
food
that post banana clarity there you go
post banana clarity amazing
well that is it for this episode of big
question thank you to brandon as always
for joining me on this episode follow
him at grindenberric he's an amazing
person follow me at mastertainment i'm
less amazing but i say something you're
pretty upset
check it out oh thank you and follow the
rockstars here on youtube and when you
do hit that notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video and if you want to continue the
conversation our new rockstars discord
server is now open to the public so if
you're over 18 and interested check out
the new rockstars discord link in the
description and join the conversation
and like sometimes we throw some you
know game shows like jackpot students
yeah
come to a game come on come on in come
do a game night with the new rockstars
discord crew but anyways thank you guys
so much for watching we love you guys so
much we appreciate you guys spending
time with us we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you